remercie Dieu tous les jours de nous
avoir réunis
quand on s'est rencontré hein Audrey je
t'ai dit que j'étais une bonne petite
chrétienne et que je me préservais
jusqu'au mariage je dis quoi dans une
seconde tous les deux
vous avez jamais couché ensemble notre
connexion repose sur une intimité
spirituelle pas sur une intimité
physique et c'était aussi une connexion
spirituelle quand tu t'es enfilé la Tour
Eiffel de Jonas Brothers
[Rires]
Paris moi aussi je dois y aller c'est
bon tu as besoin de rien mon amour merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
laissons un peu de place pour Jésus
qui va retourner sur sa terre à toi
c'est pas rien retournez dans le pays de
ses ancêtres la grande aventure pour
retrouver ta mère biologique on est si
fière
[Musique]
ok t'inquiète
trop célèbre
j'ai eu l'agence d'adoption et ils
disent qu'elle vient bon ok vous venez
avec moi mais oui grave
oh bonjour ça fait plaisir de voir une
Américaine tu fais quoi comme boulot
c'est les flics
maintenant les meufs
on dirait une capote si on se fait
coincer avec de la drogue en chinois
[Musique]
si tu sais pas d'où tu viens
comment tu peux savoir qui tu es on peut
encore la retrouver nos passeports sont
dans ma valise celle qui a été volé vous
savez qui peut passer la douane sans
souci les stars de Kpop je crois pas que
ces filles soient des chanteuses les
filles montrent leurs c'est un peu
attends
oui mais elle est là
fais tourner pas une porte c'est mon
trou du cul